we're running all the groove line
tonight that got the wheels are burn and
we we hope it don't stop we've got the
ball
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're driving all the group line pal
[Music]
[Laughter]
you
that's it and and that's that
[ __ ] uncle Joey here doing a
quick checkup with you [ __ ] you
know it's a good [ __ ] hit when a weak
burp comes out and I'm saying [ __ ] all
that nonsense I went to jujitsu I had my
meetings I got the hair through who do
they don't get him Sam and now I'm here
with you [ __ ] doing a little
afternoon tune-up perennial killing
[ __ ] the perennial og this is
my go-to
after finishing you [ __ ] I'm
gonna go to my other wait stop because
the dude called me and said [ __ ] me
he sent me an email with [ __ ]
crossbones and I checked that and the
[ __ ] net that means come over I got
the weed that killed [ __ ] Prince
Diane young
I'm tuned up I'm feeling a little I did
my little fattening tactical fitness I
had my protein shake
I had a [ __ ] nice little whatever you
know I'm trying to pull it together I'm
a fat [ __ ]
well I'm in the struggle you understand
me I'm gonna sit and embed these I give
those comics and flop and drive around
like a regular fat [ __ ] then one you got
nothing you gotta give up your whole
life cuz you don't want blood till you
[ __ ] me you [ __ ] disgust Oh get
your [ __ ] together down sucker uncle
Joey's here sparking like a [ __ ]
it's Friday payday laid a sucky sucky
day it's every [ __ ] day you
understand me that's how we gotta put
together here you suck you suck it a
little something I learned from the Bing
brothers back in 82 in New Jersey anyway
not much Jenna Chatham and it's not not
much inspiration we're going to [ __ ]
puncture along you understand me that's
the goal I want somebody to come out
periscope and say Joey I can't hang out
with you you punctured my [ __ ] lung
feeling good that home it's working I
got some CBD oil and may come on guys
come on you gotta [ __ ] do something I
could've just tapped out when I was four
18 I'm down the 298 [ __ ] looking like
Elvis before the operation is anyway
that's it that's it that's that we get
together we do a ball lie we do [ __ ]
along you don't know creepy old guy
bothering you you're trying to get you a
head together do you I don't blame you
do people around me [ __ ] even smell
like [ __ ] stopping catches
it's nice that we have this outfit Orion
to this it's nice that we're [ __ ] you
know we got these freedoms it's nice you
can I can get on you [ __ ] when
I was in Cuba [ __ ] 50 years ago be
there you can tap into you [ __ ]
with a cup of the straw a string there
we go there you go look what we got now
look we [ __ ] got now
just for another Bowl amongst us his
family this is what we are will walk big
[ __ ] [ __ ] happy family I'm saying
that gets high together what the [ __ ]
it's not buddy get on somebody sticking
a finger up your ass and make you
calling grandpa it's a different [ __ ]
story That's not me that ain't me
that's it that's that baby Wednesday
night next week the [ __ ] ice
house 8:30
Tommy Easter [ __ ] people up don't
forget that much the 420 with Tom Easton
he's another [ __ ] soldier soldier
former [ __ ] Atlanta Georgia a [ __ ]
around again his name
as well he should have been met
and that's it people get up I just
checked in with you [ __ ] make
sure you tip-top Magoo
make sure you not sit there looking at
the phone like a [ __ ] monkey I will
you've been looking around make sure
there's no [ __ ] Arabians with [ __ ]
water pistols and I said I love you
[ __ ] love my heart
without you I got all cats I checked it
when you come suckers later
make sure your world is good make sure
you good we you know make sure
everything's compliment
stay black I got you